I think they are friends I think what's
troubling to the American Jewish
Committee troubling to me is I think
there's been a change of strategy and I
think that comes as a result of the fact
that the United States today is facing a
major challenge in the world it's not
Russia it's not China and stuck Chavez
it's it's the arab-muslim world we're at
war America's at war with two Muslim
countries we may be at war with a third
not all Muslims are terrorists but most
terrorists are Muslims it's a major
challenge for the US and I think what
what we're seeing in this administration
is an effort to deal with it and I think
part of that effort is this notion of
linkage that if you could only solve the
Arab Israel conflict Messiah will come
in the Middle East and it's that notion
that analysis that is motivating
American policy and so yeah I think
friends but I think when the president
went to the Middle East Istanbul Cairo
Riyadh three times he was in the
neighborhood of Jerusalem didn't visit
Jerusalem sent the wrong message sent a
message that we're reaching out to the
arab-muslim world at the expense of our
friendship or relationship with Israel
I've been focusing on settlements
without focusing on Palestinian
incitement and stuff was another mistake
so I think what we're seeing is a policy
which sees itself distancing the United
States from Israel in order to reach out
and in some manner into the arab-muslim
world I don't think it's worked and so
many in the Jewish community have been
concerned that this nuance or non nuance
change is and I believe as I indicated
earlier is hurting prosperous appease
because if Israel does not feel that
it's only Ally continues to be his
friend
then it will not risk it will not
compromise to the extent that it has and
if you take a look at it during the Bush
administration whether you like bush or
not the first president to come out for
a Palestinian state was bush why because
Israel trusted him and sharone trusted
him to the point that when when
president bush announced the pallet that
America's for a Palestinian state Prime
Minister Sharon left his political party
because they were opposed disengagement
from Gaza happened under Bush the
annapolis dock so when it's closer now
we have no talks that in Palestinians
and Israelis are talking through
proximity which is there 15 kilometers
away nine miles away and I've got to
talk through the United States